what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today we got
ourselves a trailer for the diego luna
shout out and door baby anywho guys if
you could leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated leave your thoughts
down below also what you thought about
the trailer and also subscribe and click
that notification bell because tonight
at midnight two episodes of obi-wan
drops so we are going to record our
reactions for it take a few hours put
together so keep a lookout that's why
you have to click that notification bell
and lastly today's video is actually
sponsored by headspace when i'm very
very excited to be partnered up with
them they changed my life that was the
first app that got me into meditation
and i've been meditating for many years
since i know john does as well and this
month the headspace also has some fun
star wars themes but more details on
that after the reaction please stick
around because i'm very much excited for
it anywho let's do this
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
wow
this already looks so damn gritty
this looks intense
the empire is coming
they're so proud of themselves
so fat and satisfied
[Applause]
they're everywhere
i love this music they're watching me
now come on
[Music]
soon enough these days will end
there will be no rules going forward
that's what a reckoning sounds like
cool
definitely looks like it's in the rogue
one side of the galaxy that looks
absolutely beautiful i see a couple
things back looks like
okay so we got mom mothma back very
important rebel figure who was also in
rogue one as well and this looks like
the imperial senate right here
showcasing some of the transition it was
just like palpatine stepped in this is
part of the transition but right here oh
yeah you got that those are clone
troopers baby cool we're gonna see clone
troopers live action yay instead of just
a flashback in the boat with fett show
i'm excited about that anywho guys uh
yeah we're gonna talk more about this in
a second but first a word from our
sponsor headspace and uh again very
excited to be working with them we want
to thank today's video sponsor headspace
now you guys might have heard me say
from time to time that i meditate
regularly and it all first started with
this app headspace and it's an app that
i know john actually uses regularly now
thanks to me right it's all your fault
and so for this month they have
partnered up with disney star wars for
your find your force mindfulness series
which i think actually works in
conjunction with the way of the jedi so
well literally meditation has changed my
life i can confidently say headspace is
a major contribution to that factor so
i'm excited that we're finally
partnering up with them especially
considering it's mental health awareness
month plus it's perfect timing because
we got a ton of new star wars content on
the horizon and with their find your
four series they have sleep cast
breathing exercises and guided
meditations from some of your favorite
star wars characters including yoda
chewbacca r2d2 the list goes on you know
i've opened up about my prior diagnosis
in the past the most helpful thing has
been meditation it's something i very
much heavily encouraged one step closer
to feeling like a calm confident jedi so
if you want to download headspace and
find your force today head on down to
our link in the description box download
the app and get meditating do some deep
breathing hang out with yoda yeah i
don't really know anything about the
show to be totally frank with you guys i
didn't even know stone skarsgard was in
here i liked diego luna a lot as an
actor and door was a highlight one of
the highlight characters of rogue one a
movie that i've actually only seen one
time i really liked it but i just
haven't made the time to re-watch it
since i saw that one time in the
theaters but this has a lot that that
grit and is tony gilroy involved in this
one too oh yeah i mean he's been talking
a lot about the show and kind of going
on record saying that this is gonna take
a bunch of characters that you know from
the legacy from the canon and maybe
re-contextualize them or maybe show you
why what you know about them might not
be the truth you didn't go into super
specifics but it seems like he is
adamant about making this a bold show in
terms of choices made surrounding the
canon but also i mean like i really love
the imagery here because it does embody
that sort of rougher grittier side of
the galaxy and diego luna has described
this as being a show about a migrant and
about somebody whose you know home and
culture is essentially crushed by the
empire and who then must find a new
place to lay roots and also find a new
cause basically saying like at the
beginning of this he doesn't really care
about the rebels or any of you know like
the political situation going on and
it's about him finding that motivation
to take up arms to become an
intelligence officer to do the things
the acts that we see eventually in rogue
one and i feel like they at least here
in this tease have done a really nice
job of making it feel like a ground
level and a sort of intense show in
terms of those personal human stakes our
you know homes are being destroyed and
beset upon by this you know insidious
ideology and watching those crucial kind
of last moments before it all boils over
into the conflict that we all know and
love from star wars itself you know yeah
in some ways you know we had star wars
rebels the animated series in some ways
this is like the live-action rebels to a
certain extent not like an adaptation
but considering that this takes place
before episode four and that this is
again you know going into the rise of
the rebellion we're gonna have mon
mothman here very important figure in
the rebellion i'm excited to see like
all the nitty gritty details and i feel
like the show might actually explore
some of those political transitions and
debates as well you know even though
we've had stuff like the mandalorian
within the book of boba fett which are
you know canon and tied in obviously
this seems like it's going to be more
direct towards obviously leading into
rogue one which feeds into the bigger
development of the galactic empire oh
look jump cut there's a cat here i guess
what i'm getting at is like those shows
told these different stories well this
is going to be focusing on the wars in
star wars and a big contributing to the
development of that significantly uh if
if that makes sense to what i'm getting
at
yeah
either the political or the physical
aspects of the war as we've seen up
until this point so i think bringing
that quality to life of something that
feels more gritty and grounded and
watching the heroine take that this has
on no yeah yeah yeah no no no no no cats
get views you should have been in the
reaction for the thumbnail you should
know this you know
seeing like the heroin take that it has
on like the civilians and these
different individuals like what i
imagine we'll be seeing you know how
diego luna indoors family was affected
the development of his relationship with
k2so when you're looking at those people
and seeing the fear in them and just
really seeing the turmoil that the
galactic empire brings so much of the
time we're just caught up in you know
the the main characters or like the
badass ones who are getting involved in
the fight and it's only just like a cut
too quick to see a couple of reactions i
want this show to kind of break my heart
a little bit to see the characters in
this galaxy truly affected in a way that
makes you go back to i hate the empire
you know but yeah guys and or trailer
what did you guys think leave your
thoughts down below uh please subscribe
and click that bell because we got you
know everyone coming up tonight uh or
we'll be up for you guys tomorrow
morning and thank you to headspace for
sponsoring this video and we will catch
you guys soon
[Music]